well there have been a series of
explosions at a residential complex and
a building belonging to Ukraine's
security service in the Central City of
danipro authorities say at least nine
people were injured in that attack on
Friday night the incident comes a day
after Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski visited the city to meet
military Commanders
there were two explosions in the nepro
we are now at the site of one of the two
impacts one rocket hit the geneve
residential complex and has partially
destroyed it luckily the building isn't
fully occupied and there were few people
inside most of them were construction
workers another rocket partially
destroyed a nearby building the regional
headquarters of the Ukrainian Security
Service no people have been killed the
injured have been taken to hospital and
are being treated for minor injuries
now correspondent now joins us from the
Ukrainian Capital Kiev a step another
missile attack your antinipro talk us
through the damage
well huge damage at this geneve
apartment block which was still
partially under construction it
basically are two uh towers and one was
still being completed and the other one
has already been occupied partially and
the missile basically hit the one that
was still under completion so luckily
there hasn't been any casualties
according to the Ukrainian authorities
but people were wounded and they had to
leave their Flats because they had also
damaged debris falling down so basically
people have lost homes there president
zelensky immediately called for an
emergency meeting also because a
building next door of the security
forces was also hit and he called for
Revenge he said Russia should be
punished for this act of Terror and this
all happened a few hours on Friday night
when on Friday afternoon a roast of a
region in Russia intercepted two
missiles as well causing also dozens of
injuries from falling debris so there's
a definitely escalation here of the war
with more air air attacks but also the
counter offensive that the Ukraine has
started a month ago has now also shown a
little bit of breakthrough in the South
as they are reporting and step as we've
been saying it's been one year today
since that explosion of the Detention
Center in olanifga dozens were killed
there what do we now know
explosion there at the prison is one of
the most deadly incidents since the
full-scale invasion of Russia in 2022 it
happened on the 29th of July more than
50 prisoners of War died there and what
exactly caused this explosion is still
heavily disputed there hasn't been any
access for a full-scale
investigation I have to say the United
Nations is still calling for an
independent investigation to make sure
that the families of those who died and
also those survivors will know the truth
of what has been the cause there will be
an event later today to commemorate the
death and and this event that happened
exactly a year ago
steadfast on there with the latest
forest from the Ukrainian Capital Kiev
thank you step